the John Wick franchise keeps raising
the bar at the box office and reaching
New Heights with its stunts but there's
one thing the series has never been able
to overcome until now warning Major
Spoilers ahead for John Wick chapter 4.
you ready John
yeah
first three John Wick movies
successfully hooked and maintained Their
audience with a simple repeatable recipe
John Wick versus a lot of doomed
assassins that winning formula was only
limited by Keanu Reeves's sheer will and
director Chad stachelski's violent
imagination there is a plot behind the
violence but it's fair to say that it's
not what the audience is there for as
you watch the boogeyman stab his way out
of a literal knife Museum normal
narrative concerns such as story
progression and character motivation
take a back seat to the once in a
lifetime spectacle of it all and what
other story would the hero deliberately
provoke a horse to kick their enemy
twice what other movie would spend
nearly two minutes showing you a man
falling down every single step leading
towards sakuruku it's best not to sweat
the little things when you revisit the
Continental hotel instead you should
just enjoy the ride even if you're not
quite sure what's keeping it going in
the first place unfortunately when one
does stop to think about the finer parts
of the series story it's hard to ignore
one fact for all the ass kicking action
John Wick is one of the most passive
characters in modern Cinema in a genre
defined by Heroes taking the initiative
he spends most of the three sequels and
a completely reactionary place instead
of trying to accomplish a concrete goal
he's mostly running around trying not to
die for series with less to offer this
would be a damning issue for John Wick
it's a problem they don't really need to
solve and yet in John Wick chapter 4
they solved It Anyway the narrative
thrust of the original John Wick film is
both simple and effective Jon wants to
kill the man that killed his dog and
stole his car and his bloodlust will not
be satiated until he does so this goal
is largely accomplished by the end of
the first film and completely exhausted
by the opening moments of second in
order to justify another John Wick
Adventure the series runs into a minor
problem how do you organically find
motivation for a character who
essentially has nothing to live for his
wife is gone his car is destroyed and
his quest for vengeance is through what
else is there for John Wick to
accomplish but his own death
what though the three chapters that
followed the first film are each more
thrilling than the last John's lack of
motivation Beyond an indiscriminate
thirst for violence and revenge caused
the quieter emotional beats to feel a
bit weightless in John Wick chapter 4
however characters like Kane Winston and
even the Marquee finally forced John to
confront the emptiness of his quest the
filmmakers use the climactic duel with
Kane and soccer Kur as a point of
Revelation for Jon both men want to
escape from underneath a high table but
only one of them has a life to return to
it's possible then to read John's
sparing of Cain as a recognition of this
fact by the time Jon begins to succumb
to his gunshot wounds a welcomed yet
unexpected feeling of closure begins to
set hand yes there are several spin-offs
in development and yes there's probably
a chance Jon somehow survived his death
at the end of chapter four but for now
his story is over in the closing moments
of chapter 4 the series has the courage
to close the book on the franchise's
story in a way that acknowledges the
Grim truth of Jon's circumstances in an
operatic fashion finally John gets the
rest secure in his legacy as the most
loving husband in the history of planet
Earth and if it all ends up leading to
him cheating death for chapter 5 at
least we'll have the feeling that it's
the start of a new story and not just
another episode of a seemingly endless
quests
foreign
[Music]